vehicles and airplanes is this uh so we
got 42
ford ranger pickup cargo trucks are left
behind
22 000 humvees ambulance cargo troop
enclosure gun truck variants left behind
8998 medium tactical vehicles i was a
mechanic for those vehicles but they
call them lmtvs or fmtvs
five-ton cargo and general transport
truck
thousand five recovery vehicles i was
licensed to do that and operate those uh
they're great to drive by the way you
can run over trees at six so a thousand
five of those left behind 928 mrap max
pro ambulance combat left behind 189
armored personal carriers left behind in
other words tanks keep going down that's
76 000 right there by the way here's the
pricing
armor personal carriers such as the
m113a2 cost 170 000 each the
m57782 cost 333 000 each mine resistant
vehicles range 412 to 767 each total
cost would range around 382 million to
711 million dollars keep going over to
the next category on what we got okay
here's the helicopters 111 helicopters
60 transport cargo airplanes
we got 20 light attack airplanes 18
intelligence reconnaissance and
surveillance airplanes go a little lower
there's 208 there what's the price on
those by the way let's look at some of
the prices there
427 million dollars of uh the blackhawk
helicopters each cost 21 million dollars
okay each keep going lower i mean the
taliban one right here if you look at
what they got keep going lower to the
next part is there any other equipment
okay here we go
rifles
three oh my goodness
5330 m16s
m4 carbine ak-47s
and sniper rifles
that's
358 thousand there's only 75 000 taliban
by the way
358 126 000
and g19s
you got 64 363 machine guns 25 327
grenade launchers 12 692 shotguns 9877
rocket propelled weapons
2 606 indirect fire weapons that's 599
weapons
okay go little lord kai
what's the total number i saw 85 billion
dollars oh we got more stuff here
16 000 nine vision goggles two 120 radio
monitoring systems 22 ground anyway so
that's another 16 000 equipment keep
going lower and lower and lower is there
anything left at the bottom anything
left that we have at the bottom
the total number was what 85 billion
dollars give or take 85 billion dollars
of equipment the taliban got what do you
think about that gerard
well when you leave behind uh
a billion dollars in military-grade
assets
civilians and allies i think it's pretty
bold and audacious to consider it
leaving afghanistan that to me sounds
like a retreat that sounds like
submission that sounds like we retreated
from afghanistan we left people
but we left our people and our property
behind that doesn't also mention needs
to be shouted out the the dogs that we
left behind that are being uh cared for
by a civilian who stayed behind an
american civilian who was behind enemy
lines right now and an afghan ally and
they're both volunteering uh so once
again the private sector picks up where
government drops the ball but um
this just gets uglier and uglier and
uglier by the day and as it came out um
you know you did a great uh interview
last week about how
they're trying to paint this as first
they tried to paint it as we were
completely taken by surprised by this
then uh general miley came out
earlier last week and said well this was
inevitable we knew it was going to
happen
and he you lead by taking the troops
first they don't take their equipment
okay
uh and and this and not to sidebar too
far but this isis k stuff it drives me
out of my mind
this used to just be the mujahideen and
we supported the mujahideen when they
were anti-russia and anti-china then it
became al-qaeda in the taliban and we
had to go in and get them because of
al-qaeda but then we became allies with
al-qaeda in syria because they were
anti-assad so we couldn't call them al
qaeda anymore they were rebranded as
isis we rebranded them and now it's now
it's isis k so we have both been allies
and enemies with the same group for 20
years and what have we gotten for it
what have the american citizens gotten
for it
nothing we got nothing out of this all
right we got pain and suffering for
people who who were willing to risk
their lives and now all i heard and this
is something republicans messed up 20
years ago all we heard was we got to
protect our freedoms gotta pretend i
have still
yet to have somebody explain to me well
how we needed to protect our freedom 6
000 miles from our shores
i don't understand what we were doing
there in the first place and but since
we were there i don't understand how we
could leave like this
i i mean sam harris to his credit or one
of the foremost liberal thinkers in the
world
tweeted out i am he retweeted himself he
tweeted on january 20th after the
election i am overwhelmed with joy uh to
have adults back in the room and he
meaning elaborate meaning biden but the
biden harris uh troika all right and to
his credit he retweets himself
publicly eating these words syllable by
syllable
and that that's where we're at right now
so kudos to you sam harris kudos to to
bill maher kudos to the other liberals
who refuse to go down with this sinking
ship but uh as a country
and this is something you know that the
more conservative listeners are not
going to like i look at nikki haley i
look at donald trump jr who i find
hilarious and they're piling on to make
sure that you know that this is biden's
fault this is by dude
we know
i need solutions thank you how are we
getting people out of there what are we
doing now that we just gave a billion
dollars to people who want to do us harm
we know who to point the finger at all
right but when you point a finger at
somebody else there's three pointing
back at you right phil hey man you one
point pointing that way three pointing
this way
somebody anybody in our political
geosphere but here's the question for
you put solutions out there please
fine so what does he do what does junior
do
well he's in sales right now he's
selling he's selling that biden's
incapable but no no what i'm trying to
tell you is okay so imagine the average
voter right now that's listening to this
yep they're pissed off who isn't pissed
off today
cnn is pissed off because alyssa
milano's not pissed off well let someone
not pissed off but she's who is alyssa
milano in the first place she's the
cousin vinnie's is isn't that's the one
or no that's where i said something okay
that tells you how much i know about
them
okay i mean i know her face if i see
amanda but here's the point okay take
alyssa milano out everybody else who
isn't pissed off today cnn is pissed off
because he biting is making them look
like idiots okay msnbc is pissed off
because what
they
were his campaign it's like hey we want
this trump guy out uh fox is pissed off
because you know they're seeing what's
going on because they're pro-military
everybody's pissed off who isn't pissed
off but the average person that's
listening to this
what can they do about it what can the
average guy do about it what can junior
do about it what can what can they do
about it what can all these guys do
about it so the only people that can
really do anything about it is who
the people in charge the people in
charge so no matter how much you put it
on anybody else i'm sorry it's like dude
i'm not in charge what do you want me to
do you can scream off the top of your
lungs you can do all the things that you
want to do but what can you do so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you